[Music]
on today's show we have a long difficult
conversation about parenting
the beauties of marriage and dealing
with childhood trauma
you get to talk to a real hero on
today's show we also talk to a young man
who's dealing with pornography addiction
and shame stay tuned
[Music]
happy after christmas
what's up this is the dr john dolone
show and i'm john
[Music]
and i realize i just dated the show by
saying it's right after christmas but if
you're listening to this show
you made it congratulations or maybe
you're still in it i don't know this
show airs right after christmas right
james correct cool well i hope you got
everything you wanted
i don't even know what that means oh you
just are having a good time i hope there
was no talk of covet or politics or
anything at your house
and austin of this this is all
seriousness i know
millions of people
are dealing with loss of some kind it's
been a tough tough year
lots of jobs lots of
friends family members i mean it's just
been a
year of loss um and so i know christmas
can be tough man you circle back and
christmas and it just kind of weighs on
you so this whole season well i'm
laughing a lot about it that's how i
kind of it's how i get through tough
situations sometimes just to back up a
little bit and laugh at it and then see
where i can lean in
so man i i
i'm with you i'm thinking about you i
hope your holiday season's been one of
peace and restoration
and you get to bring some smiles and
joys to other people's lives if you're
at home and you are stuck and you just
think i just i hate all this go find
somebody to serve get out of your house
go find somebody to serve and make sure
you are still moving your body even
though it's freezing cold go for walks
go exercise make sure you're taking care
of yourself cool all right let's get to
dennis in
milwaukee what's up dennis
hey john how are you i'm good brother
how are you man
hey good
what's up hey so i uh i got a question
for you sorry i'm a little bit nervous
hey don't be nervous man i'm not that
good at this show dude
you'll be the better one on this call i
assure you
what's up we'll see about that so uh i'm
super familiar with the
process of like mourning relationships
that won't be what you want them to be
okay
and how did you become familiar with
that
my uh sorry i got to get breath
so
i i was born into just a pretty tough
situation
and uh
my uh my asus score the 10.
oh wow
wow
okay
so it's a re that's not you weren't born
into a tough situation you were born
into hell right
yeah yeah
how old are you now
so right now i'm 32 32 okay
yeah
um
how much how much healing work have you
done since then
um
basically every minute of your show and
that's about it
i appreciate the vote of confidence
dennis but i'm not that good man
okay so you've helped me way more than
you'll ever know well i appreciate that
man
so 32 you were born into the pit of hell
and
it's still got hooks in you
yeah and it it comes out just kind of in
weird ways and uh
so
right
now i've got a four-year-old daughter
and a two-year-old daughter okay are you
married and
yeah
how's that going
she's my wife is just the absolute best
she's everything that's awesome
how
how many of these old patterns are
showing back up with your little one
as
as far as my relationship with them
it's phenomenal i've taken everything my
parents have done and i've done
everything i've destroyed all and i just
rebuilt everything from scratch now
i wish that i would have had it when i
was a kid
and my relationship hey listen with them
it's just phenomenal i need to stop dude
and celebrate you
that's incredible man
you stared it down you're staring it
down you'll be staring it down
and you said not my kids no more
man
what a brave man good for you dennis
it's awesome
i appreciate that
so i actually even had a i said i had a
guy at uh that had a restaurant over the
weekend actually stop me and compliment
me and
and my wife separately on
just
how we're treating our kids and handling
them and it was just such a nice thing
to hear that feels good doesn't it
dude that's incredible man good for you
all right so how can i help man
something's something popped up
yeah um so
[Music]
my uh
my mom since she was born she's lived
really far away okay
and uh
part of her situation and and how she's
treated me as contributed to
my past but by by living far away you
said that you said that in a very
diplomatic way did she leave you and
your kid
yeah yeah
um she an addict
no and i don't know if she ever was but
she had us around
people that were very heavily involved
okay and uh was she abusive to you
directly
yeah okay
and did she let it happen
with other people
yeah okay
did she did she go to jail or she just
leave you
my uh
my mom and dad were in the process of
getting divorced when when she got
pregnant okay
and uh when i was a couple months old
she left
okay
i i know that you know this especially
looking in the eyes of your
four-year-old and two-year-old
that shouldn't happen and i'm sorry that
happened
thanks
that little little dentist was worth
more than that and i'm sorry
and so now she showed back up
yeah
how'd that happen
strange um and and one of the things
that makes it complex is
every night i tuck my girls into bed
and i give them a special touch on the
facetime and
yeah so i i give them that and i i hug
them and hold them and
just
it's just the best
and it helps me
but
it's hard to
it's hard to look at them and do that
and then think back to what was
happening to me yeah
so here's the here's the thing brother
you
are
staring down this forest fire of and
that's just to quote terrence real i
love it this forest fire of family
trauma
you're a little baby dropped in the
middle of hell and you shouldn't have
been but you were and you have made it
your life's mission to grit and flex
and become iron
in defense of those girls and your
marriage
right
yep
100
nobody gets through them
you're even lucky i'm talking to you
exactly
that's right and what i'm gonna tell you
is
that has a shelf life to it
that's what i'm concerned about
and the closer you get to see years of
when you were abused directly
when you started getting passed around
from place to place in house to house
and adult to adult
the closer your kids get to those ages
the more your brain will begin to
unspool on you
and that's what i'm worried about
consider
my four-year-old she's starting to
she's starting to ask me some difficult
questions that's right and
my policies i don't lie to her good for
you my policy is also to protect her yep
because i don't want her to ever worry
about things that i had to worry about
and i don't want her to she doesn't even
know that those things exist but
but here's the thing here's the thing
let me be super clear with you okay can
i be direct with you is that cool
yeah absolutely i called you all right
so tell me if i'm nuts
call me out if i'm wrong okay agreed
okay
yep
now that she's four
there's gonna be moments when you are
holding you are have her little bitty
four-year-old cheek in your hand at
night time and there's a little
nightlight on in that room
and you're either singing her a song or
you're telling her that you love her or
she's just babbling on about something
that you don't even know she's talking
dragons and ponies or whatever
and
you are feeling that moment and you are
a thousand miles away
definitely
and you think something's wrong with you
and you try to get to another thing to
do
and this is where your brain
plays tricks on you
and it actually it's not playing tricks
it is keeping you safe because it has
been down this road before
and this road equals
torture
yep and so in many ways
your brain is at war with itself and
this is i'm just making up two parts of
the brain here um i'm not a
neuroscientist but
just for easy math for the for the
casual listener your frontal lobe knows
i need to do these things because my
daughters deserve better than what i got
yep and your amygdala knows
holy crap
adults and kids equal war
look out yeah and so it hides it is done
fighting and it couldn't flee when
you're four or in your six or when
you're 10
and somebody's sexually abusing you or
hitting you or just leaving you at
school and not picking you up whatever
crap you went through that you should
not have experienced
your brain knows uh oh shift into
neutral we're out
and it just freezes is is that is that
fair
yeah we just hit a point at bedtime
where i i just gotta go yes yes yes and
my wife can't get out with my
two-year-old in enough time i just gotta
go that's right i feel horrible but well
no don't feel horrible
your brain's just trying to take care of
you because it's been down this road
before and it doesn't it just sees bear
it doesn't know that's a nice bear it
just seems bare okay so he's just trying
to love you
and this is where
this is where i'm trying to carve a
third path
right down the middle of this country
there's a group of people who say you
need to suck it up and flex
just do the next right thing and it's
all about yeah
and you keep your hand there and you
tell her you right all that and that
there is some merit to that you got to
keep showing up and
the other story that's told
is well this happened to you this is all
you're ever going to be
you just got to deal with it
and it's just going to be a and i don't
buy that either
there's a third way and it's both and
now is the season when the greatest gift
you could give your daughters is for you
to heal
to stop running stop hiding and stop
trying to fight it and to heal
and what that means is saying some of
this stuff out loud for the first time
ever in your life
an aces score of 10 you've read the
stuff haven't you
yeah
and all i ever see about is if you have
a score before
and i don't see anything and it's it's
starting to concern me because it should
when you talk about
fight or flight like
i mean literally i won't pull into a gas
station if i can't get the first bumper
i can get in and get out that's right
that's right i when i stop at a stop
light i give space in case i need to run
exactly i haven't i have no reason to
run but no dude you have every reason to
run because the two people on this earth
who were supposed to take care of you
didn't
they didn't
you're supposed to run brother
you are
in a similar situation as my friends who
are veterans
who pull up to a stop sign and they they
have an escape route already planned
because they've been in fallujah they
know it's coming
or their brains do at least right that's
you man they you two people are supposed
to show up and they didn't they totally
left you hanging
yeah
and there is you gotta hear me man
there is a season
where you can show up to a gas station
and it doesn't even occur to you that
someone's coming after you
you can
worry about the price for one second
exactly yeah
not dying it's it's cool just to
complain about gas prices not murder
right
there is a season where your wife can
reach over
during a movie where y'all watch on the
couch and she puts her hand on your leg
and your body doesn't tense up first
how do you know
okay
there is a season dude where the phone
rings
and you roll your eyes first your heart
just doesn't start beating
yeah okay and here's what i want for you
man i want you to have that peace god
almighty i want you to have that peace
but you gotta decide i'm worth healing
and here's where i'm gonna be can i be
unfair to you for a second
yeah okay
you've done step one two and three of
the major work for your kids
i'm gonna keep doing these things but
what will happen over time
is that four-year-old and that
six-year-old and that ten-year-old and
that eighteen-year-old
they'll begin blaming themselves for the
gap between you and them
they will try to backfill that gap with
my dad is such an amazing man because
they're gonna play the facts out
dad always keeps us safe dad always
tells us good night dad always touches
us dad always sings dad always makes
sure we have food on the table dad's an
amazing guy but they can feel that they
are not relationally connected to you
and they will blame themselves for that
yeah and that's what i'm worried about
because like
my daughter asked me who my dad is
and
i
i just stared at i didn't even like do i
even tell her his name like ah
so here's what here's what you tell him
i tell you number one that's those are
those feeling triggers that's when you
write that stuff down i gotta deal with
that and i gotta deal with mom
and not that you're ever going to take
that pain away that pain will always be
there
but it will be something that doesn't
get your heart rate up anymore
there will be people in your past that
didn't show up and now we're on to the
next but we got to wade through that
first and i'm when i say wade through it
not 18 years in therapy okay there are
some programs you can go 12 sessions and
work through this stuff
okay okay
it's the trauma focus stuff there's emdr
there is all kinds of trauma-focused
stuff there's even some plant-based
stuff that i've that i'm reading about
now for trauma like you've experienced
that's phenomenal okay
um and with the map studies and things
they're continuing to roll it out and
roll it out and roll it out all to say
is healing is there but you got to go
down the road
and it is the bravest flex of all time
yeah
but i need you to hear me say there's
peace on the other end of this man
i hear you
just a
and you know that like the a score of
four just for the casual listener a
score of four is when all of a sudden
you see these weird spikes in cancer and
heart disease and they're bodies that
just eat themselves over time
a aces score of 10 is a dramatically
shorter life span if you don't deal if
you don't deal with it
every predictive metric suggests that
you're going to have some major
challenges with addiction with
disconnection with numbing behaviors of
some sort
and your body will just eat itself over
time
are you do you have any sort of
addictive tendencies at all
uh
no
i
or unplugging tendencies i tend to call
those yeah okay yeah so i i yeah i i
tend to unplug
you can be totally alone in a crowded
room
oh yeah okay yeah you just you just go
in the deep elevator of your mind and
say bye and from a kid that was sexually
or
um physically abused that's where kids
go they get an elevator and they go so
deep inside so whatever is happening to
their body can happen they're adults in
their life you do what you're gonna do
i'm out of here but i'm still i'm i'm
it's my body but does that make sense
and that book yeah
the title says everything the body keeps
the score
your mind can hide but your body
registers everything
right and you know this i'm just i'm i'm
i'm using this to teach th the listener
too
um you know this
here's what i want you to do i want you
to be
do the bravest thing you've ever done
and you've done some brave stuff man
you're a hero to me right now dennis you
hear that
thank you like i talked to a lot of
people you're an impressive impressive
young man really impressive
i want you to call a trauma counselor in
your area
and i want you to say
i have an asus score of 10 and i'm ready
to do some healing
and if they can't handle it
they can't handle it in your area and in
a metropolitan area you're gonna you're
gonna be able to find some great folks
okay and there may be some
maybe some trial and error but you can
do it go ahead yeah i'm just i've
my wife's tried to encourage me and i'm
just so nervous just to
spill out and
unload the baggage and then
not like the person or
get judged by them or okay so here's the
thing
your story my brother is your story
nobody gets to judge it
nobody gets to comment on it it's your
story
and there will come a moment when that
story is so powerful both for you and
for those who hear it
that you'll begin to make meaning of
this thing after you've grieved this
childhood
you'll make meaning on the back end and
it will become a powerful narrative for
you and those around you
and right now that story feels scary
but if somebody can't handle that story
screw them you're on to the next
okay okay
nothing to be ashamed about you're a
dude you got robbed
you got robbed
yeah
and now you gotta call up call the
police that's a terrible metaphor but
you gotta yeah you gotta walk through it
yeah yeah
you may have to go through one or two
counselors three or four great
you're worth it your kids are worth it
your wife is worth it stopping this
nonsense from ever happening to anybody
again and your legacy is worth it
yeah
and man
i'm so grateful to have gotten to talk
to you today brother
ah thanks you're oh man so grateful so
grateful um will you commit to letting
me uh can we we call you back you'll be
on the show again in a couple of months
yeah i'd love to walk alongside you in
this um as you go to counseling for the
first couple of times i'd love for you
to keep a journal at your home
about how it's going and you can tell
people what it's like as you're
experiencing this and let me can i be
honest with you it's gonna suck yeah
it'll be real hard because you're gonna
go back to hell but you're gonna have
somebody with you this time
um yeah i'm not looking forward to that
i've
been running from that for so long so
hard that right it's it's scary to go
back but it is i stare at my kids and
and and my wife is right i gotta face it
yeah but but that's that's why you go
with a trauma counselor because they're
gonna walk with you you're not gonna be
alone
you're gonna you're gonna go to the
trauma counselor and they're gonna walk
with you
baby
this is legacy change this is setting
down those bricks in your backpack and
you've got like 30 cinder blocks i don't
even know how you're walking
the fact that you can get in until your
kids get night every night is amazing
the fact that you have found somebody
that you love and you are connected to
is a testament to your strength and
character
it's
it's so so strong
but now i want you to be vulnerable for
a season
you built up the muscle you built up the
strength and you've got relationships
and now it's time to be be real
vulnerable and real brave
and then go heal
and then go heal
[Music]
ah man i'm excited to walk alongside
with you on this one brother dennis
thank you so much for calling we'll be
right back on the dr john delaney show
hey good folks and friends and listeners
to the dr john dolone show
the world is bonkers right we all know
this and one of the most common
questions i get is how do i find a
counselor in the chaos i've reached out
and there's a six-month waiting list or
i can't afford it or they only take
insurance or i can't get off work and
time to go see somebody and it's way
across town what do i do because i want
help with my anxiety my depression my
relationships are hanging on by a thread
i want to be a better mom i gotta
process this trauma that happened to me
when i was a kid
where do i find a counselor
so i partnered with betterhelp because
betterhelp is customized online therapy
that offers video phone even live chat
sessions so you don't even have to look
at your therapist when you're talking to
them if you don't want to i've taken
away all your excuses and it's more
affordable than in-person therapy and
these are real licensed therapists if
you reach out to them you will be
talking to somebody within 48 hours dr
john dolone show listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
please reach out if you need help that's
betterhelp.com
all right we are back hey during the
break
we stepped off and dennis who were just
on the phone with from milwaukee
asked kelly about another question and
so i'm gonna bring dennis back man
you're hey dennis you're the first like
repeat call in the same show this is
incredible man
getting my money's worth today yeah dude
so what's up yeah exactly and this
advice by the way is worth every penny
you're paying for it
it's awesome
um so hey man so what's up dude
all right so yeah so i i mentioned that
my mom had come back and i
what
preston
what happened for that is my
father-in-law passed away back in
february okay
is he a good man he's a good man
he was the best grandparent that
my kids had by far he was a great man
and it was horrible man he
he had parkinson's and dementia and it
was a two or three year spiral where he
ended up
dying obviously and
my wife and i were
his main caretakers throughout that
process yeah lee dude
somebody gave dennis a break man
god almighty dude that's
that is hard
it was
horrible and
so anyway throughout this process
my mother decided that she had a calling
to come back
i bet she did i bet she's a good
grandparent for my kids
and
so i just i got to be honest with you i
always want to give my bias up front
not a huge your mom fan right now cool
yeah okay i don't want to talk crap
about anybody's mom not a huge fan but
go ahead so she she gets a call she gets
the gets the call
yeah so i've had 30 so i i've had 30
years of from both my parents but from
her too things will be better things be
better i'm gonna do more and no action
ever followed up
this year john
she's come and visited my house three
times now which is more than i've seen
her
in like a decade before that
so what in the world compelled you to
allow that
i'm not judging you this is just two
dudes having a beer at a bar dude like
what are you doing
i just always
felt
like not being the resentful nasty
person yes and
if you're gonna make the effort to
to have a good relationship i've always
tried to have my door open and it's it's
hard
but i've just been like oh
like in the past i've paid for her to
come back just to try to have a
relationship with her and now this year
she's come back and paid for herself
three times yeah and she was just here a
couple weeks ago
and my kids love her man yeah
it's hard yeah
so
a common thread
with children from with parents who
abandoned them or
from
parents who abused them
you have both
a common adult thread is a continuation
a continuing of the kid trying to go
back and heal that relationship
every kid has it wired in that why would
my parents not love me it must be me
remember earlier i was talking to you
about your daughters they'll start to
feel that gap yeah you still feel that
gap
you paid for a tiger that shredded your
heart and mind and soul you paid for her
to come back and be in your house with
your kids
and when you say it like that it sounds
insane right
yeah but there is a four-year-old inside
of you that is still going what the hell
did i do wrong
yeah and i can make it right now now
that i got money now that i got my own
house now that i got my stuff together
mom will you love me now
yeah
and
man uh you you listen to the show for
more than five minutes you know i'm all
about redemption
all day every day
but i'm not about getting bit by the
same rattlesnake twice
yeah so
on that note my specific question was
and
maybe you'll guide me differently i
don't know but how so i've
i've rebuilt an entire different life
with my wife and my kids as i mentioned
we're
we're sound in every way possible and i
had to
do a lot of work to get here
and
like is there a way that i can
how do i let the past be the past with
her and if she
is changed which sounds crazy
how have i built something new and
different with her
incredible questions both of them
the answer number one is
she doesn't have access to your kids
until you've healed
until you're okay
and so when mom can call and your heart
rate doesn't take off on you
when
you and your wife talk about mom
and you don't instantly get thrown back
26 years
when you've healed
then you can start the conversation
about what does it look like to let this
tiger back in
because you're gonna realize
you're you've grown a lot of muscles and
you're big
and you're gonna
the part of healing trauma work is
letting this little eight-year-old
that's been trying to protect you for
the last 30 years letting them off the
hook
and that's just hard to do
let them out of the elevator and that's
just part of it and again it can be as
as easy as 12 sessions
some sometimes it's harder than that
it's longer than that but you got to
heal
so um
uh i'm trying to think of i i'm just
getting flooded with lame analogies but
if
i mean if you cut yourself with a knife
you let your finger heal before you
start doing the same thing with a knife
again you know what i mean
um you're not you're not healed yet
and then the second thing is after
you're healed you sit down with mom and
have some very direct
boundary oriented conversations here's
how this is gonna go because this is my
house now
and i live through it in your house
you're in my home now
and that's not disrespectful
that is boundaries that is safety
that is you
saying if you're going to be a part of
our lives
you person who abandoned me abused me
let other people use me
if you're back in around my kids and
around my wife
it's gonna look like this
and it will be an extraordinary olive
branch
period for you allowing that
but right now you're not okay and so
when grandma comes you tense up
when you see your kids playing with
grandma your heart is out the door on
you when you grandma's behind closed
doors as one of your daughters or one of
your daughters says hey i gotta go potty
and grandma says i'll take her
right
yeah
yeah am i right
yeah no you're right so you will come
healing first
and it might be a year
hey now's not a good time for you to
come over
um i'm in some pretty intensive
counseling right now mom working through
my childhood
and when i'm ready for you to come back
then we'll i'd love for you to but i'm
not ready yet
and you leave it at that and that dude
that's going to be the first little
brick out of your backpack that's going
to become the road you're going to walk
on and your kids are going to walk on
the road and your wife's going to walk
on that road and your grandkids are
going to walk on that road and it's
going to feel a little bit lighter the
first time you lay down that first
little boundary
and then you're going to feel stronger
and stronger and stronger
but yeah brother she doesn't have a
it's
i don't mean this in a demeaning way but
you got a fantasy in your head that you
can make this all
okay and in a weird perverse way you've
done a lot of this work to prove to mom
that you're lovable now
oh yeah absolutely and
and for my dad too and that's messed up
you know what i mean
yeah yeah there's a little kid in there
man that's still trying to like look
look look i got a marriage and she loves
me and she's pretty and my two kids
they're well behaved and they follow
directions and i hug them before bed am
i doing good mom am i doing good
that's what you got to heal from
you don't got to live that life man they
don't get a vote in your life anymore
they cash that out
they cashed that out
they don't get a vote they don't get an
opinion they don't get anything until
you are well enough to let them back in
with boundaries on your terms
so can we go dark for a second yeah
what happens if mom hurts one of your
daughters
[Laughter]
uh let me tell you it's been about 12
hours she's dead and i'm in jail
you're
i haven't thought about it but that's
the first place i won exactly rage so
let me just tell you
i've seen this happen
the risk is not worth the reward at this
point
how do i
how do i have that conversation with my
kids age-appropriate and
they they grandma's
i mean they don't
they're for man
you're putting a lot
rightfully so but you're putting a lot
of insight and truth into their minds
that aren't there yet
so they will quickly
let me put it this way i took my
four-year-old my wife was um doing some
work in brazil she's a brilliant
researcher she was doing some work with
a school in brazil and
me and my son he was
two or three at the time we tagged along
four something like that
dude my son and i picked mangoes off of
trees and avocados off of trees they
were the size of my head
and we
two cans were just wild and they landed
i mean we it was the most amazing
adventure between with me and my son
like in a stroller down cobblestone it
was amazing
he doesn't remember any of it nothing
none of it man he has no recollection of
it and like you know we wrote on a
donkey out into the jungle he has
nothing no recollection so i tell you
that to tell you
your
your connection memories with your kids
are forming their their their neural
connections
their memories though are very very thin
at this moment in their life
so
grandma won't come around and one of
them may be like where's grandma be like
she's at home
oh okay when's she gonna come see us oh
she'll come somewhere sometime
okay and it'll be on to the next
it'll be on to the next
okay
so don't overthink it you're gonna use
your kids as a proxy to get connected to
your parents don't do that
draw that boundary with mom and let mom
know i'm in counseling now i'm dealing
with my childhood i got little kids and
um
you're coming back and it's all coming
back real hard and i appreciate you
coming back um but i got to do some
healing first and then we'll we'll
figure out what this is going to look
like moving forward
and that's that's tiny little boundary
number one
can you do that
yeah
dude i'd love for you to do that and
then write me an email let me know how
that goes would you do that
yeah dude that would be rad that's set
in that first boundary sitting that
first time and everybody listening to
the show this is right after the
holidays
some of y'all know i got to set
boundaries now too
very few of you will have to set
boundaries like dennis is having a set
everybody can do it
dennis you're leading the charge here
okay
all right that sounds scary but yeah you
are redeeming your story my brother
you're redeeming those bricks that
you've been carrying around they're
going to turn into pathways they're
going to turn to old brick roads that
other people are going to walk on dude
you're redeeming your story and you're
going to help a lot a lot of people
with that courage and hey mom may throw
a walleye fit
or she she may send you crazy text
messages about you're killing me and my
babies you're going to hold this over my
head why don't you forgive me
all of that is manipulative abusive
nonsense
uh you know her well you get a right to
heal
you get a right to heal
trust me
yeah all right my brother
god it's been it's been an honor honor
honor to talk to you so great man all
right we'll be right back on the dr john
dolan show
one of the most common questions folks
ask me is what they should do when
anxiety or panic strikes like a
lightning bolt i've been helping folks
101 for years but i wanted to create
something that everyone could use
anywhere at any time so i created a free
guided meditation it's not really a
meditation but really me just walking
with you through your anxiety alarms
from start to finish i'll guide you
through a breathing exercise and show
you how to lean in listen and head
towards healing it is free and it's for
everyone you can download this guided
meditation today for free at
johndaloni.com
all right let's take one more call let's
go to
jacob in seattle what's up jacob what's
going on brother
hey dr don it's a privilege to talk to
you this morning it is a privilege to
talk to you my man so what's up
hey so i was a i have a question
i was hoping you could offer some advice
um
i recently
confessed
to my wife
struggles with pornography
i've been
struggling with it off and on in my life
and
i there's these spirals of shame and
kind of the self-guilt that i fall into
um and just a fear of
being rejected for the broken person
that i am yeah um
and it
drives me to
to hide
from her to to lie to her about my
sexual needs and
um
you know and just to avoid
um
you know open and honest connection with
her and i and i want an awesome marriage
and i know that that has no
no pardon that so i was i was curious if
you could um
offer some insight particularly to um
just
overcoming that fear of rejection and
shame spiral yeah dude well number one
thanks for calling and thanks for being
brave and talking to your wife about
what's going on um did she catch you or
did you just sit down and say hey we
gotta have a talk
i uh
i
i sat her down i i heard you and uh
i heard you and ken coleman on the
ramsay show talking about
reaching out to somebody and saying hey
i need help um
and so
my wife i got home from work and i
it was the most difficult thing i've
ever done in my life uh was
sitting at you know down next to her and
saying hey uh you know i i need some
help
i've been you know struggling with this
for nine months and
and hiding it from you and i don't want
that in our relationship and i really
need help because i can't get out on my
own
um what was your response how'd she
respond
she responded
amazingly
upset and
and hurt
as as you know as as understandable as
she should be um you know that that
feeling of you're hiding for something
from me you're lying to me
um
but with so much
love and and grace
as well uh and just compassion and
wanting to help me
wanting to help me heal um but a big
part of that right now was just
mending that trust that was broken in
our relationship that i broke
so she responded really well that's
awesome man
so
how how
so there's
a jillion psychological studies about
pornography and shame and pornography
and addictive nature and pornography and
the
um
what it does to your neurochemistry
um
and so you you know all that stuff um
and so that it's
good for you for having a partner that
heard you and saw that you were hurting
um i hear a lot often i hear
men and women when they when they say
hey i'm struggling with this
um
their partner's heartbroken that they
were struggling so much and and kept the
struggle does that make sense not so
much like okay you're looking at
websites it but it's that you were in
hell and i didn't know you you didn't
trust me enough to
to reach out and so
and we're married does that make sense
and so that trust thing is often i i see
couples when they try to when they work
through this together not try to this
you all definitely work through this but
when they work through it it's about
surface level stuff like i get to check
your phone i get to see the internet so
and that's all part of it but
the deeper is
how do you learn to practice
being vulnerable in your relationship
and that's probably something you've
never ever done before is that fair
um
or you did it you got roasted
no
it's easy to talk about my past and to
say oh this is what i used to struggle
with but look at how i've overcome it
now and see where i'm at now see i'm
healed i'm good right
but but to say i'm actively
failing or actively struggling
right now um that's that's the part
that's really really hard
um
and in most you know most other areas of
my life
it's generally pretty easy for me to be
open and to be vulnerable but for some
reason this
this particular area
um
there's just a heavy
shame associated with it
that i have to
that i deal with but that so i gotcha
but that shame is an undercurrent
pornography is just the signal
the shame is underneath it
somebody told you somewhere that
things you were into
or you're weird
or you're gross
or hey shut up i don't care or that
didn't hurt
somebody told you that
your needs
sexually and otherwise
we're less than we're not valuable we're
not important to this conversation they
we're not they're not valued in this
family
and so at some point you went
underground with it
and it probably pops up in dishonesty
with a you're like you exaggerate too
much
or it probably pops up with you're
really flirty
or it probably
pops up with
uh you're over like jesus freak like you
know what i mean like super like all
into like whatever you mean i don't i
don't mean to be ugly about it but like
um
uh never miss church with your faith
community right it pops up in these
weird places and it's us trying to out
earn that shame
who we are our our feelings are things
that we thought were funny the things
that we think are injustices somebody
told us to shut up
either explicitly or implicitly the
story we were born into was you be quiet
and we learn to be quiet and then we
start trying to achieve it i'm a
straight a student i'm the super guy i'm
the whatever
i'll always be there people come to me
with their problems i'm just rattling
off the ones that i hear a lot um and
again i don't know you at all have i hit
on any of yours
i think the closest to that would be i'm
i'm kind of the the third born middle
child peacekeeping personality there you
go okay
yes
so you will earn your
receipt at the table by making sure
i'm going to be all things to all people
i need to be okay so that everybody else
can be okay
right and but you're you're okay
you being okay is you squashing
things
and so
here like
i wish it was more complicated than this
what you've got to do
is a say i'm worth having feelings
it starts from a place of worthiness
like i get to have feelings
and i get to be super sexually attracted
to my wife
and i get to
i get to have fantasies about my wife
and we're married i'm gonna talk about
him
i'm gonna invite her into those
and that's gonna be scary
and so the word i'm gonna use is
practice
you gotta start with a place of
worthiness i'm worthy
of
putting it out there
it's worth the risk
and dude you can tell her something and
she may be like what you know what i
mean
yeah and you might invite her to tell
you hers because she's got fantasies too
she's got ideas and dreams and whatever
too
and she probably doesn't know how to
tell you them
and this is going to provide an avenue
of connection for both of you that you
both don't have
i guess how do i
how do i
like what language can i use what things
can i put into practice to rebuild trust
with my wife and to
um and to practice that
open communications of
my feelings and that sense of
you know
valuing my own feelings enough to
express them and to share them so great
question um here's two things that i use
in my house
number one
i might phrase something my wife might
phrase something with the words i'm
feeling vulnerable or i'm being
vulnerable here
and that's a we've agreed in our house
when i say i'm being vulnerable here
i feel like you're
doing this just to piss me off
or i feel like when you when i got home
you just talked about this and this and
this and you just blew me off
and the response cannot be
we're going to war it cannot be a
defensive thing it has to be a
thank you for telling me that
and it's me just practicing saying what
i'm feeling because if i get home and i
feel like my wife's blowing me off makes
me mad and then i go in my room and then
i might then i go down a spiral i've
been working hard all freaking day i've
been doing this i've been it's all about
me it becomes a selfish nonsense trash
and then i come out and i'm all ready to
you know be an idiot
and so
i practice by saying i'm just being
vulnerable here
i feel like you're
ignoring me did i do something wrong i
feel like i screwed something up
and then she can say
thank you for telling me that
and then she'll look at me for a beat
and i'll say yes go ahead and respond
and she'll say
i just gotta go to the bathroom real bad
i'm happy to see you you know what i
mean it's like something so benign i
totally misread it
um or
in your situation
i'm being totally vulnerable here
i would like to try this particular
sexual act
or
i'm interested in what really turns you
on
or
the uh john doloni erotic envelope
system that i should have patented man i
got people reaching out for it have you
heard me talk about that
yeah dude
that is the best way to practice
she gets 10 envelopes you get 10
envelopes
and
i want you to dress up in this way i
want you to fill in the blank
with whatever's in your head
and the vulnerability is you're both
going to open it you don't know who's
going to get who's and you may spend an
entire evening french kissing and
watching love actually over and over and
over again that might happen
and you may find yourself in a suit on a
who knows man whatever weird things come
up in these envelopes
but it is a way to
make the awkwardness
of your feelings
be in the envelope not in the
conversation it's a way to put it it's
again you hear me talk about writing the
letters all the time it's a way to put
at arm's length there's a distance on it
and then you could go okay it's in the
envelope and then she
part of the vulnerability is her going i
i don't even know how
what how does that work or i have a
question about that and then y'all are
in it now
and that's the good stuff man
and this happened with raising kids this
will happen with hey i'm not happy at my
job
uh you know pornography and sex it
becomes this just it's a way to
disconnect
and numb out and unplug and not have to
deal with the potential
for rejection and you've got a life
field of it
is everything is anything i'm saying off
um
i think
i think it's pretty close i think the i
think the biggest struggle for me is is
mostly just it's not so when it comes to
okay i wanna i want to engage sexually
in this way i'm
completely satisfied with our
our our sex life there's
i wouldn't change a thing about it
you're not satisfied with you
yeah one of the most common things
people say when they had an affair has
nothing to do with the
their partner it has to do with who
they've become in that partnership
and there's that aliveness that risk
their heart starts beating faster
and you as you're clicking away and
clicking away your heart's just being
faster and you might get caught it all
is this
it's all uh esther paralysis it's desire
it's this whole
new emotional thing that is new to us
and you can decide to have that with
your wife
but you practice it
and you lean into it so it's not about
it might be for some people it might be
about i want to try this sex position or
this like that might be it
but bigger than that
it's deciding i'm going to practice
desire i'm going to lean into the
eroticism that is my marriage i am going
to be totally vulnerable and she might
squash this
middle kids aren't don't have can't they
don't have time to be vulnerable because
they got a whiny little younger sibling
and they've got an overbearing older
sibling
you know i don't have time for
vulnerability i got to get through the
day i need you to be okay you'd be okay
and what i'm telling you is you're worth
it all
i'll tell you quit looking at porn dude
stop and i know that sounds so like dude
i've got just quit
throw your computer out the window turn
the wi-fi right off just stop
just stop
okay i wish it was more complex than
that have somebody you can call get one
of those internet filters put enough
barriers in front of you
then you stop
get rid of all the streaming services
get rid of all the stuff just stop
is that fair
yeah and my wife and i we've put up
we've put up all the barriers it's i
think
more than just having the barriers
between me and finding some loophole to
finding
you know pornography
i want the kind of relationship with my
wife where i can
i can
you know
tell her
something
as it comes up or before it comes up
before it happens i want to rely more on
the relationship that i have with my
wife of openness
have an accountability partner
right now not your wife you're gonna
bury your wife with that
if you call your wife four times a day
and tell her hey i really wanna look at
porn right now i'm just really
struggling you're gonna drown your wife
call your accountability friend and then
at night time you tell your wife i
checked in with my accountability friend
today
she doesn't need to know the details of
what you know what i mean
yeah
and you're gonna bury her with that
have somebody you can let the raw
ugliness out with
and um
but don't don't use her as a garbage bin
yeah because what will happen is you
will start to find your body will begin
to connect those conversations with
safety
you'll begin to need to dump that stuff
on her and that's not her job her job
isn't to carry all of your crap with her
all the time
yeah right
so
do this
i'm gonna sound it's gonna sound
backwards
act better and just be different don't
over sensationalize this get an
accountability partner somebody you
trust whether it's somebody at your
local church i'm a friend of your
whoever and you say dude i'm struggling
with this thing i'm gonna holler at you
or i'm gonna shoot you a text
and
i want here's the most important thing
okay you ready you wanna you wanna solve
this thing sooner rather than later here
it is
go to walmart go to target go somewhere
and get a small little
journal
and every time you feel an urge to look
at pornography
i want you to just stop and take an
inventory of what's happening in your in
your world
are you tired did you eat a bunch of
junk food did somebody just reject you
are you waiting to get feedback on
something from work
are you feeling lonely
what is the feeling i'm trying to get
you to create a gap a small little space
between the act of going to the website
why why is my body trying to take care
of me why is it trying to numb out right
now
why is it taking a cheap alternative
connection right now
and once you can establish why your
body's doing that
then you can you can it's like right
when i'm about to reach for a twinkie or
a gummy candy i'll stop and go what what
am i doing oh i'm really tired right now
don't do that you're just tired
or or go eat a monster salad or go get a
steak or something or
when i find myself in my room in with
the door closed and then i'm in my
bathroom with the door closed and i'm
just sitting on the floor with instagram
and i can just go what what what am i
numbing out from
what am i hiding from
hiding from nagging i'm hiding from
snacks can i have a snack i'm just
hiding i need to stand back up and grow
up and go back in there and if there's
some behaviors i don't like that i'm
going to lead into those behaviors and
be direct to them
i'm going to be vulnerable i'm going to
lean into that but it's just getting
that gap between the behavior and as
soon as you start to call it out you're
going to start to notice it everywhere
and then you're going to realize i don't
have to numb this
i'm sad i don't have to numb this i'm
going to call him and ask him i'll get
there my report and i don't have to numb
this i'm going to ask him for a raise i
don't have to numb this i'm going to
tell my wife i've been missing her
or hey honey i don't feel connected to
you when you get home whatever the thing
is
but separate yourself from that act and
this goes for anybody who's trying to
to not overeat as you are making your
news resolutions listeners this is for
everybody
i'm going to stop swearing so much i'm
going to stop eating like that i'm going
to start exercising and stop sleeping
whatever the thing is i'm gonna start
being nicer to my spouse or to my kids
whatever it is
right when you feel the impulse to not
just pause just get a gap what's the gap
what's the gap puts the gap what's the
gap what's a gap
what is my body trying to protect me
from and when you solve that man you
solve all this stuff you solve it all
thank you so much for the call brother
jacob you got this man you got this
all right as we wrap up today's show
man we're going back to the master gary
clark jr off the black and blue album
song's called please come home
man he's so good it goes like this
my love is with you even though you're
far away
you made me love you
and that's where my love will stay
darling those times i get lonely you're
the own you're the one who truly knows
me
i can tell it in the way darling you
show me why don't you please come home
girl come home girl you've been gone way
too long
come home girl
my days go by slower my nights are
getting colder soon my heart's going to
strain ah this is such a great old blues
song
why don't you come home girl
gary clark my man gary clark jr
right here on the dr john maloney show
you